leah thomas
uh
born and went through puberty and indeed
competed in swimming competitions
um
asmail
just won the just won
one or more uh ncaa swimming
championships in the women's divisions
leah thomas wins an ncaa swimming title
there
leah is
um
before i say anything more about this i
i would like to know
what the hell the university of
pennsylvania
is thinking
and um what this person's parents think
about this
remarkable transformation
from loser to winner is really what the
transformation is because there hasn't
been that much transformation of
the underlying maleness of of this
person
what we find in this
in this article
is
thomas's triumph in atlanta indeed her
very presence at the swimming
championships as a contender came amid a
far larger storm particularly in state
houses and right-wing media
about sports participation by
transgender girls and women
it is incredible it is utterly
incredible that recognition of a
depending upon how you count 500 million
to 2 billion with a b
year old reality
can be
dismissed
by the new york times
as the purview of
right-wing media
why why would the new york times the
grey lady is that what it's called
yeah yeah yeah why would the new york
times
which once prided itself on being the
source of news for americans at least
the source of print news for americans
pride itself on abandoning all reason
and i mean this the
the binary nature of sex in our lineage
which is at least 500 million years old
is recognizable by everyone
it is recognizable even
if you're a cat
who
doesn't have all of his parts anymore
he's still a boy yeah he's still a boy
and
this
oh i'm sorry i didn't realize i was
still on but you can keep me on here
zach let me just read one more one more
excerpt from this new york times article
thomas
again
born went through puberty
competed as male
thomas and her rise though forced the
typically plotting ncaa to grapple more
quickly with a subject that scientists
are still examining
and its consequences for sports
competitions
comprehensive research in athletes is
still lacking but early studies suggest
suppressing testosterone in transgender
women decreases muscle mass and
hemoglobin levels reducing how much
oxygen can be carried through the
bloodstream
most of the changes occur within the
first year of hormone suppression but
transgender women may still have more
muscle mass than their cisgender peers
even after three years
as some insist that no amount of
testosterone suppression can undo the
physiolog physiological changes linked
to male puberty like taller height and
larger hands and feet others dispute
that transgender women have a built-in
advantage and have argued that inclusion
should outweigh competition
i have a few things to say here yeah
inclusion should outweigh competition
this is sport
if you want to go
swim with your buddies
and there's some question about whether
or not you want someone to participate
you can talk about whether or not in
this case inclusion should win the day
but in sports it's about competition
it's not about hey i want to compete
because guess why i know i will win
because i'm going to be cheating by
competing in that division
so here are just
a few there's there's abundant
abundant evidence here but um i happen
to have you can you can show my screen
here i happen to have written a
article back in 2019
over three years ago for my patreon um
that i have opened up it's publicly
available should trans women compete
against women in professional sports no
and i i joke here that this is a short
article i did go on though
uh to uh to to make a number of
arguments and i recommend i recommend
that you follow them but one of the
things i do is also
point to this
uh
this table which it turns out here let
me see if i can find it
is
in
okay zach just give me my screen back
for a second while i find
yeah uh the table in question
oh
boy
nothing is working that's snakes that's
totally different isn't it
um
okay well i don't unfortunately it got
closed when when my computer crashed
earlier so i'm gonna go back in here and
just show you this here i will i will
link to the actual actual paper that
this is from
um sex you can show my screen here sex
differences that suggest male design for
combat in humans this is from if memory
serves a uh
um
sorry 2012 paper called the importance
of physical strength to human males
and just some of the some of the ways uh
that males and females are different is
that males have greater upper body
strength taller bodies heavier bodies
higher basal metabolic rates faster
reaction times thicker bones in the jaw
faster mental rotation and spatial
visualization that's the bit where
you get shown something you're asked
what would happen what would it look
like if you rotate 90 degrees to the
left something like that
more accurate throwing more accurate
blocking of thrown objects more interest
in the practice of compact skills combat
skills stronger bones greater bone
density specifically in the arms on and
on and on and on
and more recently and here
you can show yeah you're still on my
screen good um
here we have this paper
published in sports medicine in i think
it went online first in 2020 and it was
officially published in 2021
a review
by emma hilton and tommy lundberg called
transgender women in the female category
of sport perspectives on testosterone
suppression and performance advantage
a very compelling
review of all of the evidence which
finds to
no one's surprise if they are thinking
carefully about this
that taking a single metric for whether
or not you are male or female which is
to say circulating levels of
testosterone at the moment
and deciding that that's the thing that
you're going to count and and use to
decide whether or not you're male or
female and used to decide whether or not
you have any advantage is woefully
inaccurate i mean in inadequate and
um frankly if you've if you were born
male and if you went through puberty
mail
and
um and you have recently been on
cross-sex hormones but retain
basically every other
other manifestation of maleness
competing against women is cheating
that's just true
all right i've got a number of things i
want to add yeah
one i always
we are facing
a an epidemic of sophistry across
every domain it's a true epidemic i mean
it really is right and the point is i
hear you making points that shouldn't
require they don't need to be made
frankly i mean look you can win this
argument in one move if you're held to a
reasonable standard right
does anything that we do
in the
medical practice of transitioning
males to trans femaleness
change the height of the individuals
who have been
transitioned
it doesn't right or the skeletal
structure maybe maybe bone density my
point is even just one parameter that
the fact is you know were you a tall guy
yes
are you gonna be a
tall woman we don't know
yes we do in fact you're gonna be an
exceptionally tall woman because you
were a tall guy and you're not gonna get
shorter i mean maybe maybe you get a
little shorter but you don't get a lot
shorter so anyway my point is this is
obvious right this is this is really an
emperor has no closed moment
is it fair for
somebody to go through puberty as male
declare themselves female have
procedures whatever they are and then
join women's sports
no
simply no because one thing we can say
is this doesn't fully reverse
the transitions that male puberty
uh
causes the body to go through right it's
a simple
simple conclusion pre-puberty boys and
girls have much more similar both
interests and skill sets right
now
um second thing is
oh the new york times is interested in
the question about how we you know
balance the
desire to be inclusive in sport
uh with the uncertainty of the evidence
as scientists mull over this question
right follow the science new york times
find better scientists any scientist
who's confused by this isn't really good
at their job go look at the hilton and
lundberg paper and you know one one
thing so i have actually hilton emma
hilton and colin wright and i have
written a couple pieces together so i i
know her and she's terrific
but one of the things that we had talked
about sort of behind the scenes was
people would ask us
like well you know what what's you know
what are the primary what's the primary
literature what's the scientific
literature on the idea that men and
women are different right and like it's
it's actually too obvious ever to have
been written down that way yes
what is the scientific evidence that
plants are inferior at warfare
well if you can't produce a piece of
primary literature it must not be true
and furthermore i'm really hoping that
you have a randomized control trial for
that you're better you'd better have a
randomized controlled trial because
otherwise the you know the trees that
are best at warfare
i don't know something but okay so
you know the new york times is is is
wrestling it is grappling with the
question of inclusion versus scientific
certitude oh boy are they wrestling
which is
total sophistry because i would
point out that the very nature of
women's sports
uh makes uh clear that inclusion is not
the goal
right why are men not ordinarily
included in women's sports right right
because there is a value in having
sports in which women can actually
compete on a level playing field with
other women and not face the biological
disadvantage
that sexual dimorphism has exposed them
to what about the woman who came in
fourth in the race that leah thomas won
right why isn't she included on the
podium where she belongs exactly now
i'm also you asked a question about what
leah thomas's parents think yeah i did
and you know in general i don't i don't
love that sort of approach but in this
case i really do i really do wonder
actually legitimately well i i found
myself in a different place on the start
okay which was wondering about leah
thomas
and here's the point um let me just be
clear about this we have said many times
when we have discussed transness on this
uh on this channel that
we do not regard transness as inherently
a malfunction right there there's too
much transness in too many populations
and there are long-standing traditions
about how it is addressed now that is
not to say anything about medical
transition or anything like that
however or the rate at which it is
prevalent now right in the west right
which could be the result of all kinds
of
disruptive
influences but it is not inherently
malfunction okay
but here's the point
what does it say about a person
that they go through
life
mail they go through puberty mail
right they go through competitions mail
they go through competitions mail they
then let's say that they
genuinely feel they're born in the wrong
body fine
do they not look at their victory in a
competition like this and feel
embarrassment
right the point is look
okay
so you're trans
why are you picking a realm
where
you have an advantage from your having
transitioned rather than having been
born in the other body why wouldn't you
pick a realm where you're not cheating
and everybody knows that you're not
cheating right so i guess the question
is what is the state of mind of somebody
who could actually go home with a medal
from an event and feel good about it
right i don't understand the feeling
good about it and i it's not that i you
know i want people who
experience transness whatever it is
to find their true selves and to feel
good about it right but
this this ought to make anyone feel good
right this is that's right this is
cheating and you know getting a medal
through cheating you shouldn't look at
the metal and feel good
right now you you should not
and um
the fact that
a good part of the world can see
what's wrong here
is is is one thing
and then that there's another part of
the world that is somehow willfully
blinding itself
because it's been told that in order to
be a good person that's what you do
in order to be a good person
you
uh move the syringes out of your
twitter bio and move in the ukrainian
flag in order to be a good person
you talk about how amazing it is that
leah thomas beat out a bunch of women in
swimming
even though it's utterly obvious that
this person would do so there's no
sportsmanship there there's
you know this person was a competent
enough swimmer to be doing middlingly
well as a male swimmer until basically
yesterday
of course leah thomas is going to win
against women
and if it were true
that it is not true but if it were true
that there was some mechanism for
reversing
all of the advantages that come through
male physiology and male puberty
then there would be a
well-defined literature that would
describe the pattern so that we would
know how many years had to pass with
what kinds of therapies before the
advantage had been neutralized and you
could join women's sports and the reason
that there is no well-defined literature
and the reason that the new york times
finds itself grappling with the question
of scientists who can't figure this one
out is because this is political it is
not scientific right
the inability to get to the answer is
the point and um
you know and i guess
how many different realms do we need to
see
nonsense masquerading as science before
we say oh my god what has taken over our
scientific system and what kind of
danger is implied by that breakage yeah
and i guess i i finished that patreon
article that i that i showed
um by saying
also
uh i will call
i will call people trans women
uh i have
avoided doing that in this particular
case because this looks
this looks like transitional sophistry
at some level
um
but what i won't do
is call women cis women
or men cis men although
it's not really that surprising that
that's not where this fight is taking
place
and
i will also
not
say
nor do i
believe that
given again the 500 million to two
billion years of evolution
uh
that is that is part of our lineage
that the statement trans women are women
is true
women are women
trans women is a new category
and
it does not have a 500 million to two
billion year history at all it is a new
category
and
we can be
kind and compassionate
and um
and respectful
without throwing out reality and being
unkind uncompassionate and disrespectful
to all of the women who are being hurt
by this the children who are being
harmed
uh the you know it goes on and on and on
and society and i just are reckoning
with reality that takes a hit every time
we are told to utter one of these
completely wrong-headed and insane
sentences like trans women are women
yeah now
i think
i would say my policy is i will treat
trans women as women or trans men as men
for every purpose where that does not
harm somebody else and the basic point
is at the point you get to things like
prisons or
sports uh then
we have to we have to look at the
reality now i would point out i went to
leah thomas's wikipedia page
and um
it it it has this shocking feature which
i i would recommend people go to it and
read it it's not the first time i've
seen it where the thing is written in
such a way so as to tread
carefully around the modern convention
of not quote-unquote misgendering
right and so the point is it is cleverly
written even from before it's like it's
like the
the sexical end of dead naming it's like
dead sexy right exact it's dead sexing
and um so what they do is in places
where it would be you know
obviously this person has a history as a
boy and then as a man and competed as a
boy and a man right and so instead of
saying you know and didn't win races he
competed blah blah blah then
transitioned now she competes right that
would be a
literal if we accept that she is a she
that is a literal description instead
what they do is where they would say he
they say thomas right the last name
um
right so as not to be so is to be gender
neutral and then at the point that the
person has transitioned they say she
and
uh even worse than this in the case
of um chelsea manning
right
i have seen the new york times rolling
stone magazine and i believe wikipedia
all engaged the fiction that chelsea
manning delivered documents
to julian assange
which did not happen that is
historically false right so here's the
question if this is also clear because
because
i can't even remember his name at the
time bradley manning did that
and later transitioned in prison maybe
even right uh came out in in prison yeah
yeah
i mean it is
it's like it's like the opposite of
reality and it does it does once again
feel very post-modernist it's what i
currently believe
is not only reality but it has always
been reality and the fact that i didn't
always believe it
doesn't change anything which also
leaves me open to changing my mind
tomorrow at which point that has always
been reality and if you believe me today
and then don't update your understanding
of my belief of reality tomorrow in
keeping with my understanding then
you've slighted me it's a
microaggression for god's sake it might
be a mega aggression who knows it's
actually it's a kind of weird immunity
from hypocrisy or from being you know
convicted of hypocrisy right to change
your mind you should acknowledge that
you've changed your mind to be able to
go backwards and say oh i always
i always believe that i always was that
is nonsense and this actually comes to
the point for me which is the solution
to this problem it
wikipedia
should absolutely be steadfast in being
able to write i mean wikipedia is a
dumpster fire at the moment yes but
wikipedia of old that aspired to a
neutral perspective
should simply write stories that track
the person's
presentation their gender at the moment
that incidents happen bradley manning
gave documents to julian assange uh in
prison bradley manning
came out and said he was chelsea manning
and has been treated as chelsea manning
ever since right that should be what's
written
and the idea that we can't write that
because we're treading lightly around
sensitivities says that we are not
dealing with objectivity and i think the
solution to this
involves
rational trans people confronting this
right and actually we saw this a bit
caitlyn jenner
came out uh against the competition of
women and uh of trans women in women's
sports and the basic point is look i'm
defending women it's the right thing to
do um and you know uh uh why am i
forgetting uh a buck angel transfer
grandpa has also been very good on this
issue and so look
there are a number there are a number of
people most not quite as
as public as them but i i know some
trans people too who are actively like
going to for instance um you know state
um
state hearings
trans people saying
trans people should not be competing
um as the sex that they were not born to
right in
in sport trans women
and um and it's it's powerful because
these are people who actually do have
the yes lived experience of
of the
of the pain and horror of the gender
dysmorphia
that actually causes some very tiny
number of people um to to transition and
the people who are abusing
uh the ability to transition and for
example compete against uh you know
women
those people are robbing trans people
who are just trying to live a life with
extra complexities exactly right and so
i i really do hope that there is a an
emergence of uh you know a wise
consensus amongst trans people who spot
how crazy this is
[Music]